we have the equation 20 minus 7 times X
is equal to 6 times X minus 6 and we
need to solve for X so the way I like to
do these is we just like to separate the
constant terms which are the 20 and the
negative 6 on one side of the equation
I'll put them on the right-hand side and
then we'll put all of the X terms the
negative 7x and the 6x we'll put it all
on the left-hand side so to get the 20
out of the way from the left-hand side
let's subtract it let's subtract it from
the left-hand side but this is an
equation anything you do to the
left-hand side you also to do the
right-hand side if that is equal to that
in order for them to still be equal
anything I do to the left-hand side I
have to do the right-hand side so I
subtracted 20 from the left
let me also subtract 20 from the right
and so the left-hand side of the
equation 20 minus 20 is just zero that
was the whole point they cancel out
don't have to write it down and then I
have a negative 7x just cat gets carried
down negative 7x and then that is equal
to the right-hand side of the equation I
have a 6x I'm not adding or subtracting
anything to that but then I have a
negative 6 minus 20 so if I'm if I'm
already six below zero on the number
line and I go another 20 below that
that's it negative 26 negative 26 now
the next thing we want to do is we want
to get all of the X terms on the left
hand side so we don't want this 6x here
so maybe we subtract 6x from both sides
so let's subtract 6x from the right
subtract 6x from the left and what do we
get what do we get the left-hand side
negative 7x minus 6x that's negative 13
X right negative 7 of something minus
another 6 of that something is going to
be negative 13 of that something and
that is going to be equal to 6x minus 6x
that cancels out that was the whole
point
a bynes subtracting negative 6x and then
we have just a negative 26 or minus 26
depending how you want to view it so
just negative 13 X is equal to negative
26 now our whole goal just to remember
is to isolate the X
and we have a negative 13 times the X
here so the best way to isolate it is if
we have something times X if we divide
by that something will isolate the X so
let's divide let's divide by negative 13
now you know by now anything you do the
left-hand side of an equation you have
to do to the right-hand side so we're
gonna have to divide both sides of the
equation by negative 13 now what does
the left-hand side become negative 13
times X divided by negative 13 that's
just going to be X you multiply
something times X divided by the
something is just going to be you're
just going to be left with an X so the
left-hand side just becomes an X X is
equal to negative 26 divided by negative
13 well that's just positive 2 right a
negative divided by negative is a
positive 26 divided by 13 is 2 and that
is our answer that is our answer now
let's verify that it really works that's
the fun thing about algebra you can
always make sure that you got the right
answer so let's substitute it back into
the original equation so we have 20
minus 7 times X X is 2 minus 7 times 2
is equal to is equal to 6 times X we've
solved for X it is 2 minus 6 minus 6 so
let's verify that this left-hand side
really does equal this right hand side
so the left-hand side simplifies to 20
minus 7 times 2 which is 14 20 minus 14
is 6 that's what the left-hand side
simplifies to the right-hand side we
have 6 times 2 which is 12 minus 6 12
minus 6 is 6
so they are indeed equal and we did
indeed get the right answer